welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down episode 5 of She-Hulk the
new entry is filled with Easter eggs
hidden details and a lot of things that
let us know what's going to be happening
in the show throughout this video we're
gonna be going through it all and I am
aware at the moment which is why this
video is a bit later than usual so huge
apologies if you haven't been able to
sleep because you were worried about me
I haven't found something better to do
with my life you can all relax I'm still
a loser without the way a huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into
She-Hulk episode 5. foreign
[Music]
she was getting served papers in regards
to Titania taking the trademark of her
name in this entry we see her and Jen
going to court against one another which
has tie backs to the comics as they
ended up fighting in one during the
first major She-Hulk run we know from
the trailers that Titania will return
once more and I think she could be
revealed as being the one that hired The
Wrecking Crew we'll talk more about Todd
later on in this video but I think that
she's going to be set up as the main
villain for a number of reasons firstly
she's been all over the social media for
the show and she's popped up in several
Twitter posts and promo videos secondly
her name has been slasher at least one
news report every single entry thirdly
her origin story ties in the She-Hulk
and in the original Secret Wars she was
created through doctor Doom's
experiments that involve Jen her first
fight was also against Jen which started
off a major rivalry between the two
similar to what we're gonna be getting
here Titania is very much in opposite to
Jen as she's a Superhero with no skill
and has a marketing team behind her so
she can secure the fame she craves Jan
has actual powers and abilities but she
just wants to be left alone now though
this episode ends with her being
defeated I think she'll try every way
that she can to make sure she takes
She-Hulk down titled mean green and
straight poured into these jeans it's
the shortest entry we've had so far
clocking in at 30 minutes with the intro
and credits the title refers to Jen's
dating profile for She-Hulk and this is
used as a way to prove she was happy
with the name before Titania took it
whereas we normally get news reports
opening the episodes this entry begins
with an advert for Titania She-Hulk I
kind of feel like the entire thing might
be a play on Gwyneth Paltrow's range of
beauty products goop and you might
remember that there was a bit of a
kerfuffle online because she was selling
candles that smelt like Tony Stark's
fingers or at least that's what I told
my wife also last week I said is a joke
yeah that my wife left me because I got
caught liking pictures of She-Hulk and I
had people going
um your wife left you but She-Hulk
doesn't exist mate and if you don't
understand sarcasm then you probably
also don't have a wife so [ __ ] you
anyway yeah love that you've checked out
the video again and the ad has a similar
style to Gwyneth but I'm guessing that
this is just the usual style for ads
like this so let me know below if you
think that you know a one that it's
closer to also I don't know if Marvel
would be like [ __ ] you pepper pots now
the advert boasts about strength which
is of course she-hulk's main ability and
he's pretty much still in her entire
image I can't get sued for ripping off
new rock stars kinda good phew yeah make
the arrows yellow and no one will notice
now Titania is everywhere including
Billboards and ads on podcasts we hear
journalisting to the pro se podcast in
her car which in real life is a legal
one that discusses the law Jen's cousin
Chad shows up asking for She-Hulk to
sign some products which shows how
Titania has entered every aspect of her
life hilariously this includes a title
sequence which is a really cool fourth
wall breaking thing in which Titania
thanks the audience the signing with
Chad actually ends up showing up in the
credit scene and we get a quick shot of
a Titania car that says signed by
She-Hulk which is being sold by the
character Titania is called the snake
oil salesman which in case you don't
know is a phrase that was coined during
the Wild Wild West this phrase described
con men that would travel from town to
town selling tonics that apparently
cured all ailments these days that
doesn't really happen and the term just
means someone who sells valueless Goods
that don't do what they say now the
color of the snake venom is pink
representing Titania and the rest of the
products are green which represent
She-Hulk the snake venom one is of
course vicious or as the green ones are
connected to Beauty symbolically showing
how the two differ back at the office
Jen shows how attached she actually is
in the name even though before she tried
to focus on being herself however being
She-Hulk is opened a lot of doors for
her including the job that she now works
at pug goes to Nikki to ask if she'll
stand in line with him for some Iron Man
3s which are sneakers that we've seen
advertised throughout the series these
also pop up in the credits and we can
see they resemble the Mark 42 which was
the main suit Tony used in Iron Man 3.
however there's also lots of different
characters here some of which are really
interesting we get Frogman ones who will
be popping up in the series there are
some Cyclops ones referring to the X-Men
Deadpool the thing Captain America
Spider-Man Captain Marvel ones and also
ones that belong to storm now She-Hulk
is obviously a very fun show but I'm
taking this as 100 confirmed that all of
these characters are in the MCU this
proves it I'm not having any more debate
this proves it they're already here
Deadpool here things already a thing and
Spider-Man obviously exists though we
don't know who he is we learn poke is a
drip broker that's called Alonso and
this might be another Marvel producer
Victoria Alonso also it might be a reach
but a drip broker could be a play on the
power broker AKA Shannon Carter however
I do think it's just an odd to Victoria
who's put things together and she's sort
of held the entire thing by the seams
and threaded the pieces with one another
might also be another costume created
from The Incredibles and we get that
same sort of sassy attitude Nikki
realizes that she can get Jin an outfit
and Jen decides to focus on the
titaniacs now Pugh and Nikki travel to
Boba which is sort of connected to the
superhero clothing and inside we catch a
QR code which will get you a free
She-Hulk comic if you scan it this is a
barber Cafe but the name Boba is a play
on the phrase bow which means boyfriend
or lover the other guy plays it down at
the front it's eventually revealed with
a bit of racism that he actually sells
superhero stuff but it's not exactly
what they had in mind this includes a
Hulk Tale with a character wearing a
Borah thong some Avengers sorry Avengers
boxers and mugs a title Hammer that I
own that I mean that my kill owns and
some Captain America Shields we can see
that these unofficial due to the names
and the colors being wrong on the shield
and this is why the guy was worried they
were cops he's actually selling
counterfeit goods and is this a bit of a
stereotype and you might have seen one
of his Avengers mugs before in the
credits images when we caught Jen
holding up one in court to use it as
evidence a quick segue to let you know
that if you want to support the channel
we have a merch store over at xero
Edition which is linked as the pin
comment we've got a better call Paul
t-shirt on there now so if she Hulk is
giving you lots of lawyer Vibes or you
just like Better Call Saul then
definitely head over there we also have
a sea urchin one so you can make sure
that damn punks like Jared know that you
won't put up with their crap huge thank
you to everyone who's got one so far we
really appreciate at the channel and it
helps to make videos like this so yeah
it really means a lot thank you and from
here we go to the secret a door to see
them rocking that sweeter bungees merch
and you know marvel just ran people out
of town who make this count of its stuff
it's gonna get to the point where I'm
willing to pay 200 just to get in a
bungees T-shirt with a purple Hulk
because it showed up for three minutes
in this show I want to also get those
Iron Man 3s you [ __ ] anyway pug is going
full Captain America and end game as
he's carrying not only the shield but
also the Hammer as well now he's just
getting some focus on the side
characters and this was one of the most
fun parts of the season so far for me
elsewhere Janice called him by Holloway
to ask why his new staff member is out
advertising booty boosters similar to a
couple of things we've mentioned so far
these end up showing up in the credits
with Holloway even drinking one he seems
a bit annoyed by the booty boosters but
if you think that's bad then you should
see the Meltdown the internet had over
She-Hulk shaking hers with Megan the
stallion ruin the bloody ruin the bloody
MCU
Oh She Hulk is given a lawyer to handle
a lawsuit and this is where her side of
the episode really gets going and
Mallory Park is a really interesting
character but they show to take focus on
though Marvel never fully leans into
everything from the comics there's a lot
of things that they could be doing with
her if we look at the source material
and the car makes Mallory was a Next
Level lawyer that was a nickname the
face that never lost a case she was
extremely formidable but due to all the
chaos that gem brought into her life she
ended up starting to hate her she became
the chair of fourth wall Enterprises
which a bit on the nose but they had a
Sinister plan Burke and the group wanted
to build their own version of She-Hulk
and she would be created as someone they
could control again this could tie into
the DNA plot and you might end up
working with Titania so that they can
secure it this could then fold into the
stuff with the Wrecking Crew and bring
together all of the plot lines instead
of just having fractured ones popping up
throughout the show now she does tell
Jen she can do better and the pair drink
together eventually but I feel like
there is a rivalry that's gonna build
between the pair anyway Jen brings up
both doctor strange and Thor who both
use their real names which is why they
can't be copied there's lots of
hilarious cases of this in real life
where the guy in the UK taking the name
sings Breeze to play off Sainsbury's but
he got sued and changed it to Mara sings
instead of Morrisons now there's also a
million different plays on KFC but
Titania has straight up jacked the name
making it a different story they connect
the A and B storylines after Mallory
suggests she gets some proper clothing
and Titania calls her Shrek I feel she's
more of a Fiona but but I digress I've
seen the memes at this point Mallory
ends up arguing her case to the judge
and she goes to how She-Hulk was first
mentioned by the public which we saw in
the news reports that opened episode 2.
Mari wants to put these into the record
tying back to this moment we have a
number of news items and broadcast
quotes I'd like to enter into record now
Titania argues that she's not the Sham
Hulk and she talks about how she has
tons of testimonials from Bots like my
subscribers Titania side argues that
She-Hulk was only interested in the the
name once it became successful and we
see footage of her leaving Court saying
that she doesn't want it however Mallory
plays a news interview from episode 3
that was advised by Blonsky at the drip
broker we get a nice little line on the
blood which of course is how She-Hulk
was able to be born basically she's an
adventurable Hulk is her cousin
my blood yeah initially my man drip
doesn't want to do it but he realizes
that there's a challenge in having to
fit both her and Jen back at the office
She-Hulk gets a bit of a surprise with a
returning character have you checked out
a last breakdown then you'll know he
talked a bit about Todd who will be
played by John bass who said that he
sounded very similar to the member of
the wrecking crew from episode 3.
impenetrable skin yeah my skin is
impenetrable at least with anything on
Earth even vibranium Once you turn into
She-Hulk I couldn't Pierce that nasty
green skin damn it Paul's gonna be mad I
didn't see anyone else mention it but
the fact that he was the only person in
The Mask made me think that they hid his
identity for a reason he of course also
brought up penetrating her skin and it
was a weird thing to drop in a
conversation unless he was talking about
penetrating something else so since then
a lot of other info has come up with a
character including his name in the
credits before Disney changed it up
originally he was listed as Todd Todd
Hulk making me think he's gonna tie
massively into the blood plot and
potentially even get some of her DNA not
like that you dirty bad boy now John
messer's character was also discussed
heavily by the creative team in the
build up to the series and they said
that he's gonna be a sleazier version of
Tony Stark who's just basically a rich
guy that keeps popping up everywhere
therefore I'm kind of expecting him to
appear in a number of episodes going
forward and for this amazing twist to be
revealed that I've amazingly predicted
now if it's not it's just another fan
theory for the trashy but hey my stuff's
not been too Off the Mark recently has
it so if I get it wrong then please
focus on the stuff I got right now I
kind of think that this Rich thing might
all be a friend and that he could end up
being bankrolled by either Titania or
The League villains I'll talk about at
the end of the video might not be on
Titania's side she might not have hired
The Wrecking Crew because he does
testify against her but yeah there is a
potential spoiler at the end who could
be behind it also stick around until
then or leave straight away if you don't
want any spoilers couldn't end up time
with the Mallory Buck thing as he is
meeting with her and she might be the
one who hired her but yeah going wild
with the theory time at the moment I'm
not going to drop a theory time but
those are the theories now though gen
regrets going on that date she realizes
that because her dating profile had her
name on it that she can use though she
met his Witnesses it says one of the
things she's looking for is a sturdy
king-sized bed and she of course broke
the one in episode one this was a call
back to the comics in which he also
broke one in the opening of The Dan slot
run after transforming into her biggest
after not scare off her date he once
more get the return of the dates
including David attunga who in case you
don't know was a wrestler that used to
be a lawyer he used this as part of his
character and we hear the others going
through their experiences the guy she
hooked up with belittles her and says
that he wouldn't date Jen which knocks
her confidence a bit and in the comics
this got to the point that she used to
prepare to remain in the She-Hulk
Persona to avoid all this nasty sort of
comments about her now back with a drip
broker she gets given a suit along with
something else which will likely be her
comic book accurate costume the episode
ends with the drip broker putting away a
special costume and this of course
belongs to none other than Daredevil a
daredevil coming back is probably the
aspect of the show that I was looking
forward to the most cause I hate women
and I [ __ ] hate jokes as well anyway
he of course came back for no way home
in his Matt Murdock Persona and we now
have him in a new costume that's
slightly more in line with the comics
it's sort of a Best of Both Worlds where
he gets the yellow that was originally
part of the boxing leotard that he all
but it's infused with a Netflix design
Matt's father was a boxer which spawned
that original look and then it evolved
over time interestingly the show has
flipped things up from the comics and in
those she was happier on her She-Hulk
Persona preferring that over accepting
who she viewed as being plain and
interesting here though Jen is more
interested in being herself and the
she-hulk's stuff is definitely an
afterthought a daredevil will of course
be popping up in Echo before going onto
his main show called born again this is
of course based on the Frank Miller
graphic novel it's also very much a meta
joke on how he's back with Marvel and
going in a New Direction now from here
we roll into the credits and this is the
first episode where we don't get a
post-credit scene although this was
super short I actually enjoyed it the
most out of the episode so far I do want
more from the series at the moment but I
think this was short and sweet and it
had some cool little moments in it
obviously the big thing everyone is
going to be talking about is the last
few seconds of the entry I think what
came before was pretty fun I think this
was put there so so everyone comes back
next week and though I'm not completely
gripped by the series I will indeed be
back for that overall you know fun entry
I'm not gonna hate on it like I normally
do just had fun with it and yeah that
that was my thoughts great review as
always now for the next part of the
video I wanted to talk about the leaks
on the show about who the big bad really
is these aren't confirmed but super
duper scooper Daniel rbk has put a post
out on his patreon discussing who the
true villains are you don't want to know
that then I suggest that you turn off
now and huge thank you for sticking with
me until the end those stupid cops
turning off my [ __ ] video
so kill I'll kill them all anyway you
you guys get to live because you kept
watching but according to Daniel it will
be revealed that the villains are the
intelligentia this is a group made up of
the world's smartest super villains that
are probably pronounced wrong and we've
seen a number of different members in
them over the years this includes
Murdoch who we know will be popping up
in Ant-Man Quantum Mania and the series
could end up laying the foundation for
what's coming in that movie next year
however I also think that it might
feature the leader who we saw the
origins of all the way back in the
Incredible Hulk a d23 confirmed that he
will be coming back to the MCU and that
the villain will appear in the upcoming
Captain America movie titled new world
order this will see Sam Wilson facing
off against some greater threats that
have Arisen in the wake of the snap Tim
Blake Nelson will reprise the role of
the leader and he's a bit of a strange
villain to have cap face up against
typically in the comics he is of course
a Hulk villain and I'm guessing that he
will pop up too I think that the series
will be the perfect place to have him
show up and perhaps we will get a post
credit teases his arrival before he
shows up in the movie abomination of
course also popped up in the Incredible
Hulk and he got brought back for this so
it makes sense to have the villain that
was teased in that turn up in the series
now we also have leaks at the rumored
World War Hulk film will feature lots of
different versions of Hulk characters
therefore I think it's gonna be more
like World War hulks with an s on the
end and this is a really underrated
sequel that's looked over quite a lot I
think the graphic novel for it might
even be out of print but it has such a
good story if we're involving lots of
Hulks pick it up digitally if you can
but it basically centers around the Red
Hulk and a new character in The Red
She-Hulk Elita is one of the main
villains too and he's responsible for
the creation of Red She-Hulk which would
be a good adversary to have gen face up
against this is eventually revealed to
be Betty Ross and it would be awesome if
they brought back Liv Tyler too
unfortunately William had passed away so
we can't really get his Red Hulk unless
it's fully CGI but I don't know whether
they would be willing to do that due to
showing respect to the the dead actor
either way that's what the leaks are
saying and let me know below what you
want to see in the show just to let you
know we're running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of
dollar and thunder on the 15th of
October all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
it and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now save that to you
then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of one of the trailers from
d23 we've covered secret Invasion
werewolf by night and also the
Mandalorian so definitely head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sticking through the video I've been
Paul you've been the best and I'll see
you on the next one take care peace